嘿，你聽過 ABBA Voyage 嗎？就是那個把 ABBA 樂團用虛擬偶像的方式，搬上倫敦舞台的演唱會。
有啊，聽過。聽說做得超逼真，但成本高到嚇人吧？好像是專門為了那個場地打造的，沒辦法搬到其他地方演。
對，這就是今天我們要聊的。最近倫敦有一家叫 Unit1 Studio 的公司，他們拿到 23.3 百萬歐元的融資，就是要解決這個問題。
解決問題？怎麼說？他們打算讓每個人都能看到虛擬偶像演唱會嗎？這聽起來有點出乎意料耶。這種東西不是應該越稀有越值錢嗎？
其實，他們就是看到了 ABBA Voyage 雖然受歡迎，但那個「單一場地、高成本」的模式，讓很多想做虛擬演唱會的藝人卻步。
嗯，這點我是信了，畢竟如果每次都要投入那麼多錢去打造一個新的場地，那根本沒幾個人玩得起。
Unit1 Studio 的目標，就是要打破這個限制。他們的創新點在於，他們要將虛擬偶像演唱會「標準化」和「模組化」。
標準化、模組化？意思是像組樂高一樣，把演唱會拆成好幾個部分，然後可以隨時搬家、隨時組裝？
沒錯，就是這個概念。原文有提到，他們成功把 KT Tunstall 的虛擬演唱會演示，從一個測試設施，搬到倫敦新的永久工作室，只花了四天。
四天！這速度確實很快，以前這種搬遷肯定是又貴又耗時。所以他們具體是怎麼做到的？是靠什麼技術？
他們的 CEO Barney Wragg 提到，他們的技術讓開發成本大大降低，而且可以在任何地方複製演出。他還說，他們的目標是讓這些演出能在十二個月內收回開發成本。
十二個月收回成本，這確實很有吸引力。但這種技術會不會讓虛擬演唱會品質下降啊？畢竟 ABBA Voyage 的成功，很大一部分是建立在極致的沉浸感上。
這點他們也考慮到了。他們的團隊很強，除了 CEO 本身是音樂產業資深人士，還有創意總監 Jonathan Butterell，以及技術總監 Pavle Mihajlovic，他還是電玩工作室的共同創辦人。
甚至連 ABBA Voyage 的超寫實虛擬替身創作者 Greg Meeres Young 和 Sefki Ibrahim 也被他們挖角過來了。這團隊陣容確實很堅強。
所以，他們不是要犧牲品質，而是要找到一種，既能維持高品質，又能降低成本、快速複製的方法。就像 Daniel Waterhouse，那個 Balderton Capital 的總經理說的，Barney 解決了一個產業裡「大家都知道存在，但沒人能搞定」的問題。
這樣聽起來，對於我們這種一般創業者或中小企業主管來說，可以學到什麼？
我覺得，最關鍵的就是「拆解問題」和「標準化思維」。如果我們手上有一個很棒，但成本很高、很難複製的產品或服務，可以怎麼把它拆開？
然後找到哪些環節是可以重複利用、哪些是可以簡化流程的？這就好像把一道功夫菜，變成可以量產的調理包。
嗯，我懂了。就像我們開小吃店，原本一道招牌菜很費工，只能限量賣。如果能把備料、醬汁製作這些流程標準化，就能提高產量，甚至開分店。
對，就是這個意思。那如果是一般上班族呢？這種概念能怎麼帶入工作或生活？
我猜啦，可以把工作中的複雜任務，拆解成幾個固定步驟。就像寫報告，可以設定一個標準模板，把資料收集、分析、撰寫、排版都模組化。
沒錯，這樣下次再碰到類似的任務，就能更快完成，也不容易出錯。甚至可以把這些經驗分享給同事，幫助整個團隊提升效率。
總之，Unit1 Studio 的案例，讓我們看到了，即使是看似高不可攀的頂級體驗，也能透過重新思考商業模式和生產流程，找到普及化的道路。
嗯，好像也提醒了我們，很多時候的限制，其實只是我們還沒找到對的方法去打破它。